hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to star wars battlefront now
full disclosure EA did approached me and
offered to pay me to play this game so
this is a brand deal but as with most of
my brand news I would never play a game
that I didn't actually enjoy hey get
back here and number two I always take a
moment to use this as an opportunity to
do some good in the world so I will be
taking the proceeds from this brand deal
and I will be donating $10,000 to the
make-a-wish Foundation because it's one
of my favorite charities and I myself
have completed two wishes for various
people also if you remember Schad leech
or Patrick was his name he started up
his YouTube channel and I will be
collaborating with him very soon because
he's been doing a lot of good work I
would have done it sooner but things got
a little crazy towards the end of last
year so without further ado I will get
to the game and I'll show you how
awesomely amazing I am at this game I'm
gonna go ahead and assume that I'm gonna
be good because I do play this game a
lot of my own
not a lot anyway I'm not high level but
I'm decent so there's that I I don't
suck I'm not I'm not the worst that ever
existed I'm not a not ashamed I'm bad
okay I said it I'm bad at the game I'm
bad those Rebels comes and/or Imperial
douches are gonna get it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I know I know defeat the enemy
I know shoot the bad guys whoever they
may be whoa who's that is that our guy
why I saw you there ah he got me with
his gun cannon I spotted him though so
you know I helped probably oh look at me
where did he go oh my god hahahaha
victory I am gloating and in defeat I'll
blame you for some reason for cheating
because I'm pretty sure that's exactly
what happened
shoot you harder I don't know if I can
you're shooting as hard as I can choose
got one of them okay I helped with that
I don't know I didn't give me any credit
but I definitely helped
it was my lifelong group no that was
mine how could you betray me truck door
new mundo new dough Newton new Dom low
uh-huh that hurts a lot in my face I'll
nailed that reload I'm so skilled except
I'm about to die huh
duck and cover cowardice is the only
option who is shooting at me Ramona I
see you I see you not uh I'll preface
this I much prefer a mouse and keyboard
I'm pronouncing keyboards pretty much
anything in my is that a hero that's not
the [ __ ] Droid was in like a new hero
that they introduced but man that did
not go well for that person whoa my
friend just got blown to smithereens
good thing he'll respond soon yes I'm
missing on purpose it's a stratagem huh
they're behind me he's flying Juicin Oh
God oh yeah did you guys see that of
course you saw that I was recording it
ha ha ha see in victory I gloat very
hard who's locking onto me thank you
this seems to be dicey Hey
faster cannon that seems potent I'm
probably gonna die you went up here oh
oh I don't know if it's gonna help at
all I mean a fortification can only do
so much
let's see what happens I am shooting
very hard
oh they're behind me I have it behind me
like God behind me it snuck up on me I
should probably change my loadout but
I'm just too stupid to do it friend
friend go soak up bullets for me friend
thank you that wasn't the objective ah
okay
success is my only reward and I'll take
it
frankly I wouldn't have anything else ah
lots of them
Oh God hello oh hey he's just six lucky
lucky man oh I want that I'll try that
out I'll try that out
looks like I'm facing off with somebody
right here oh come on
what's hippedy bomb I almost had that
guy Sean John Sean John seems to be my
nemesis here he probably wouldn't
consider me his nemesis but I've been in
assume he's my nemesis cuz I got no one
else to blame for my faults and he's
destroyed she's through does impact
grenade that means that it explodes on
the contact of thing and do this oh god
I better charge he won't expect it yes I
got him he didn't expect it this guy is
seeing as he's sneaking up on me but he
wasn't was that Sean John good it's
almost like I beat jontron which is my
only goal in life if I can name drop
enough names yeah I'll be very happy
ah okay I see you damn you huh I got
somebody not gonna try to risk that
season's is a difficult game death dafuq
that's a death the Imperials I was
trying I was deafening as hard as I can
f whoa 11 and 6 it's not terribly bad
especially considering I jumped in that
game halfway I must try a different game
mode I love this game I really do like
when it first uh when it was like doing
its beta I was playing it over at the
game grumps office and I was like
addicted to it and then I went home and
downloaded the game overnight and then
the next day I was gonna play it but
then the pay day ended cuz it
like a two-day beta who's not ok it was
very sad I'm all I can almost guarantee
that I'm not gonna be able to get some
good power-ups here but maybe a walker
for a little bit but whoa hey hey hey
now come on now come on come on now
let's not be ridiculous
oh there was such a hit oh that was such
a hit I got robbed there I got robbed by
lag or something I'm gonna blame
everything my dad works at PlayStation
and Star Wars
hey is General Grievous just not good
situation
oh he was right on top of me that's why
I was dying he was in my face oh I got
deft see this is another problem having
a big game it's very easy to become a
casualty of war and that everything is
exploding around you so death it's
obvious none of these hey wait this guy
hey hey yeah you better run you better
run better run
oh god I better run I better run I
better run I'm Anton run not a coward
aah I reload no no no I got ya with six
health left let's see if I can scope us
sweet headshot after it oh I want eat I
want tea oh I want yes yes yes
ha ha go kami I always say when I'm like
I immediately go for it and then I
probably almost always immediately get
killed directly our friends
oh well that's not good missile from sky
missile from sky indeed Oh God I'm gonna
I'm not gonna last long like the other
side is like on their game they're like
on their a game but there I go but I
killed someone man though they're there
their air superiority is no joke I got
nowhere with that oh I got robbed again
again who was directly on him I mean it
wasn't a headshot but you know he's kind
of go oh that's not good yes
oh god no ah - standing on a hill like a
goof Oh got a pickoff the people trying
to pick off our walkers I'm not gonna go
for the tie interceptors I didn't expect
someone to be there we already have a
walker down we're losing this is the
last like I guarantee this is lost he
was gonna slow I'm so scared
did ya we're done we're done walkers
explosed we're done we're done we're
done death dance upon us uh death
Oh God death so much death too much
death effect oh no that's just how the
cookie crumbles
Wow I was doing so badly and I was still
number 6 on my team they had a guy that
was doing 41 and 9 that was rough ok
let's get out last that game woof that
game did not go as planned
I mean even though I was doing very
terribly in my mind
apparently in comparison to the rest of
my team I was doing quite good so that
is Star Wars Battlefront I love this
game and of course full disclosure EA is
obviously paying me to play this game
but I would never play a game for money
that I didn't actually enjoy I'm not
gonna peddle a game to you they do not
pay me to say that I like this game I
honestly like this game and of course
I'm donating a portion of the proceeds
that they're giving me to charity and
you can check the proof of that in the
oh I'm not lying about that I love
taking these brand deals as an
opportunity to do some good and help put
money in the right hand so I highly
recommends game just as a base of that I
enjoy it I'm not paid for an opinion on
this I honestly like this game and think
you guys would have fun playing it it's
a lot of fun even if you're in a bad
game where you got terrible teammates
that just happens but thank you again
everybody check the proof of my donation
down in the description and let me know
what you think of this game in the
comments below and check the description
where you can get the game for yourself
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video sit down get all